have you seen this I don't think I've
seen this one hey all right highly
recommended my assigned he's like you
have to watch this so I recommended
stamp of approval here we go here we go
I'm not having a boyfriend is it
yourself or you nobody's pursued you
it's kind of like it's never lined up
with the right person
careful careful welcome to the button a
speed dating show you know it's gonna be
good they broke the button I can't
believe it either player may press it
and swap out their date for a new person
get out of here if two people can laugh
God I hate them
second date this is the button hi hey
I'm Daniel I wonder if people follow the
same pattern as last time well yeah
probably it seems like it's the same
video every time it's the same video
well surely not everyone can be terrible
people no no no they can
nice to meet you nice to meet you Joyce
I like your sweater thank you she hates
the sweater come on that's what it sucks
this look that's pretty trash
if you play the piano let me get with
you like music or something a lot more
people do that but like whatever they do
they have to incorporate like in their
style oh yeah yeah I like this guy that
was a pilot he had like uh everything
like a pilot t-shirt a pilot coat hanger
I don't know and it's just like okay we
get it can you imagine we do that with
YouTubers
I feel embarrassed just walking around
with the camera outside I'm like people
are gonna think I'm a vlogger I don't
like this there are people asking me
like can what do your tattoos mean I'm
like I don't know like I like video
games
and they just kind of sit there waiting
for more and I'm like that's it when I
was a child my grandfather
gaming Son and one day you should love
games so much do it for years I'd do it
for you grandad
I ain't represent my right
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's my birthday today and the only
thing I want for my birthday gift is
that you buy the new PewDiePie G fuel
shaker cup collector edition this
collector box has been designed by my
amazing talented and beautiful wife
admires you look at it it's so cool it's
so cute
she also made this one
he feel is of course the greatest drink
of all time I say that in my like
PewDiePie voice but I actually mean it
it's my favorite drink
you just mix it with water you don't
have to stock up your entire cupboard
with a bunch of drinks and support your
favorite Creator thank you and marzian
check out the collector edition get the
Shaker or get the tub or get them both
and if you use the code PewDiePie this
week only birthday week you get an extra
30 off you are welcome everyone be like
I would have made but they have to if he
takes me then you get 30 off it cancel
out you're good I got you deal
right
yeah yeah I love music I'm a radio show
host and who's your favorite artist he
likes music what no way he likes music
and he's a radioactive wow I figure you
have to hate music to be a radio show
host because I always play the worst
stuff hey got him radio hosts are the
worst I'll add that to my list of
terrible jobs
like I can't see but it sounds like you
actually looked away to find a notepad
[Laughter]
what we got here real estate agents
Uber's number two
if I ever become
um king of the world king of the world
okay yeah right if you become the ruler
of the planet yeah these jobs they will
all be gone I don't want to say anything
too drastic what will happen to them but
they will be done nice well you just
definitely deserve it and anyone that
didn't support me or like try try to
make me become king Overlord right right
you're haters you're haters yeah they
will be sent to Mars so you better start
now the haters Must Die
now I'm not saying I'm not saying that
oh I'm not saying that I never said that
anymore yeah with no oxygen just
so you better start right now everyone
that subscribed you're already doing it
but everyone else
I got bad news for you so what do you do
I'm a designer designer yeah okay Joyce
likes to eat cheese and banana I'll push
the button yes but have you tried it
he's a banana
so you would press for this girl
psychopath obviously she's putting
banana goes
I go sometimes do you put banana on your
pizza would you put banana on your pizza
Felix
I thought it's not that bad
button
Psychopaths I made a video I think it
was like it wasn't Keg's cooking but it
was something like it and like banana
and meat like sliced meat and it wasn't
actually that bad I mean bananas tasty
and meat's tasty yeah okay yeah I think
you're making the argument for me that's
right double tasty but I mean if I
imagine she has a banana and has like a
piece of craft singles like the American
sliced cheese and slaps on the banana
like a hot dog and eats it it's weird
no there's only one way to settle this
kin
let's wait did you did you do not come
back with a banana and some goddamn
cheese
there's only one way to know for sure no
don't do it you animal
no I hope she wasn't lying
do I put it on top of the banana
there we go
what kind of cheese is it
from McDonald's
opportunity is pretty good
are you eating it
it's not bad it doesn't go but it's not
bad bro
I wish I was just eating parmigiano
and then having a banana maybe but not
like the the cheese guy the flavor has
to be so strong you don't even taste the
bananas
you're totally right that's totally
right it's like cheddar cheese like like
really sharp cheddar and like a banana
like almost right yes
yeah Daniel why did you reject her that
was so sad yeah well you know hi there
tell me yeah dude what do you mean say
it was the banana and the cheese I know
it's because the banana it did do that
high-pitched thing when she said she was
a designer
wow
that's amazing oh crazy
whenever people do that to me I'm just
like you don't give me that you can't
just say you hated it or some [ __ ] is he
practically just dead whoa are you still
eating that banana
well I gotta finish it that's true I'm
not too long I'm not doing that I'm not
doing the Chiefs thing at least that's
pretty weird that's weird you get voted
off real quick
my name is Daniel McKenzie Mackenzie
nice to meet you nice to meet you so why
did you and your last girlfriend break
up well um
before really I've seen her on one of
these before yeah she's back again I
guess she didn't win huh she didn't get
that second date she's gonna come back
and try again princess you'll see her
but she doesn't want to go see me that's
who I where'd she live uh Portland oh
that's not even that far I know right
three hours it was frustrating this is
how he talks apparently
push the button you see her hands oh
she's ready she's ready go see me that's
who I where'd she live uh Portland oh
that's not even that far I know really
three hours it was frustrating
I love that well caught Ken are you a
good kisser am I a good kisser who would
say no so what about you I think I'm
pretty good yeah I think so I've never
had a complaint
wow
oh got her oh that was close
this guy's good yeah he's good look at
that why is she making that face like
she's surprised she's right at the
button too
he got me first oh no is this like who
can press the button fastest game it's
the same he's got nothing that's the
game the game is to push the button
first it's not to actually last and get
the free date or whatever all right
Mackenzie you've been rejected
oh it's so close
oh we weren't into each other we were
just waiting for you to go red
hey how are you my name is fair enough
dude can you imagine listening to his
radio show and he's like oh God welcome
to 98.5
he'll be first tomorrow I'll rather than
the
radios
maybe it's a great radio show I don't
know but that freaking no it's not I
think is it the audio is the shotgun mic
so they got in here it's freaking
piercing my ears though
nice to meet you I'm Daniel
so how was your day going are you
feeling nervous are you feeling good you
know I'm a little I'm a little nervous
there's this little thing that I've
learned that a friend taught me that if
you do get nervous do a couple push-ups
and like get your mind are you gonna do
something I don't can I yes do some
push-ups
yes why don't we turn red yes yes
you play yourself
yeah these are push-ups yeah oh wow
that's crazy you're still less nervous I
do actually why did you reject Daniel he
has terrible form he didn't go down all
the way
[Laughter]
I didn't like his piano sweatshirt
either very much good oh I respect that
says the girl wearing her Grandma's
freaking shirt
this is a cute top I love the piano just
not the sweatshirt
Carlos Carlos and Carly I love that and
I love your tattoos also appreciate it I
love everyone like the handshake bro
they were like down with it you know
they're like the whole thing don't ever
shake my hand like that because I will
know where to do what the [ __ ] you're
doing always crack jokes whenever
someone does it to me because like yeah
we always mess up and go what are we
doing let's try it again like every
single time
why do people insist on doing it then
because everyone [ __ ] it up we just met
you [ __ ] idiot I don't know what this
is it's like after you do like the you
know in the do you do you snap
afterwards because some people do the
snaps yeah exactly I don't know your
game it's a weird guessing game I hate
it don't you can do it but don't do it
the first time
I actually don't ever do it that's the
reason I moved to Japan everyone just
bows it's great and they don't touch you
it's just fantastic even hugs is like
weird do they have any like cool battles
that are things that I like like hit a
bow and like spin around and snap or
anything like that the [ __ ] are you
talking about I mean they got cool
handshakes if you have like cool back
yes yeah
that's a good point well there is like a
subtlety to it some people have good
balance I will say I got a good buy
yesterday I was like damn that was good
what makes a good bow like a good snap
to it straight back just boom boom yeah
yeah yeah that's it oh no I love the
bound see you even bow or just kind of
Nod your head I just counted on my head
yeah
thank you how old are you 36. nice I'm
24. is that too young for you um what's
your normal age range
27 to 42 pretty much oh he spelled it
out
we can't take it serious though why I
feel like you would grow way more mature
faster than me and then you'd be like
all right I'm out of here but then when
that kind of like bring us back to level
zero then since you're older than me
it's almost better than if we were there
I don't think so this is flirting Ken I
do like I think that's great though
you're looking at that you're waiting
for that red light that's correct yeah
Carly in these videos it's always the
person that asks the most questions who
wants to push the button they don't care
enough to tell talk about themselves so
they just like exhaust you with
questions and they're like yeah that's a
good point yeah anything you said but
yeah sure I'm sure you're great that's a
good it's a good stride it works we'll
see if she wins never had a boyfriend
really never so what shies you away from
not having a boyfriend is it yourself or
you nobody's pursued you it's kind of
like it's never lined up with the right
person
careful careful don't touch it
he's he's the one that said she was too
young he got played if she would have
answered the question she would have
said he's too old whatever it is who
cares all right
that was scary
how are you feeling button
a little beat up
hey what's up what was it set to set
here nice to meet you what how's your
day going are you feeling nervous not
really oh wow that's amazing I feel like
I wasn't nervous until I walked in here
and now I feel nervous let's do a little
talent show okay is that too I hear
you're really good at armpit Parts my
best friend just learned how to armpit
fart she was mad I haven't learned it
yet I'd love to see yours I mean no do
they have what the [ __ ] yes all right
you gotta make it wet I don't know about
licking his hands when he puts in his
work that's a little weird
if I can still do it you wanna try all
right I'm already trying give me get to
mine I don't know let's see
oh I got one oh
I can't do it anymore
under there now
the coolest one where we could do it
like this
it's cool man it's loud
so I've just added noises and will look
cool
whoa oh my gosh
holy [ __ ] if he gets buttoned now I have
no faith and this will ever work no
he deserved it after that
how can you say no to that I had to add
that sound effect there's no way that
was real that was just like a straight
up yeah jeez
his face I respect your decision yeah of
course
do it for you I press the button as a
defense move not really an offense move
I'm trying to go on a second date with
someone that I like and he wasn't going
to pick me so I didn't pick him either
hey oh Oh weird
jacket oh thank you what was your name
sorry I'm Josh Josh nice to meet you my
name is Carly Harley awesome have you
always lived in Seattle or Washington I
was born in Virginia I grew up out here
yeah I just moved from Kentucky about a
year ago we're in Kentucky
um I went or I lived in Lexington I went
to school at the University okay I drove
through there a few times yeah this is
how Americans communicate
it was a ton of other places they're
from and you have no yeah I'm talking
about yeah I have no idea I'm like what
the [ __ ] are they saying is this
interesting to anyone
if I don't tell me I'm from Wisconsin
whenever people like if I'm in Australia
or anywhere else that's not American but
not American ask me where I'm from I'm
like the Deep South they're like oh cool
wear it and I'm like you don't you're
not gonna know there's no point in me
telling you I'll say it near Texas and
they're like oh yeah I know where Texas
is why why did everyone pretend like
they know it too I get this a lot
especially when people ask we're in
Italy we lived I don't want to dox
anything but it's like it's a specific
place but it's near a very famous place
so you just first say the specific place
and they're like oh and then you say
that like the place they will know for
sure and they're like oh yeah
they're like where are you from and they
like all the way down the details I'm
like I'm from Mississippi and they go oh
I've heard of that you don't have to
know it doesn't matter it's near
Nashville or sort of kind of close to
Texas oh yeah yeah okay okay it's like
me saying I'm from Gothenburg they're
like I don't know what is that that's
Swedish what is that Virginia is really
close there yes
whoever asked questions pushes the
button whoever asks the questions that's
what they should rename it I thought
this was in LA the whole time too but
apparently it's in Seattle yeah yeah God
I thought Seattle lands were better I
thought they were better than this I
think she might have been too young to
be honest hot how are you doing good
that's good I'm Josh Debbie Debbie nice
to meet you nice to meet you how tall
are you I'm 6'3 oh wow I like them
exactly so I think you might like me ask
him he's sitting down he just say [ __ ]
he's not six three yeah it's like I'm
telling you I'm like eight eight ten
measure me you know you don't believe me
whatever
super super tall
although when I said I always hunch over
and I always look around I'm like [ __ ] I
know these people aren't taller than me
but I look like a [ __ ] Smurf over
here why do I have to sit like this but
they can't be comfortable sitting like
this why are they doing these like hello
I am saying yeah straight up I said
normal hello
I'll lean back I'm like freaking
slouching on my chair yes what's up
you want to go to date with me or no oh
I I was actually I'm the same height as
these guys
can you believe in do they have you
sitting into a smaller chair
I was sitting on the floor actually
what
right
what there's an optical illusions here
even like your head your body is just
smaller than theirs how do they do this
thank you for their back it was like
Lord of the Rings they shot it they're
like you want to do something cool this
is actually how it looked like
didn't you tell me you were taller than
me at one point we've Stood Beside each
other on several occasions um
you're massive like a little one
directly below that down there
right on the on the right yeah look at
that look how much bigger I am the news
oh yeah well what about these oh no
we're both standing up not the pie oh
rest in peace Rebel mode oh how would
you seduce me I don't have to take my
time to continue to get to know you I
got a deep voice I've been told my voice
is like somewhat nice talk dirty to her
sorry
pretend that you're talking to me on a
phone oh no oh sorry Debbie Debbie no
that was dirty Josh as hell that wasn't
dirty you're giving me an out there that
was far from Dirty that was uh on the
spot why did you reject her I think a
little too too too old potentially why
don't you ask her how old they are like
if they're such a big deal like whatever
yeah she's already looking at the button
she's already measuring it out like
she's like taking this opportunity like
okay the button's that far away flip my
hand over easy it's forgive me now what
inspired that uh my mom's favorite
flower and my favorite flower yeah I
have a few you have a sleeves and then a
half sleeve and a chess piece nice um
what inspired you to do that
give each other your best pickup line
why does everyone's tattoos have to have
a story but it's usually because people
that don't have tattoos are really
curious because they're thinking
themselves about getting it and I think
they build it up too much in their head
like it needs to be something like oh
dude all this thought about like oh this
Branch represents the courage that my
cat has in 1996 a plate fell off
and cut my toe and I had the thought of
a tree outside the window yeah some yeah
people always ask me they're like did
your tattoos hurt and I always give it
to him like I'm like oh yeah it was
awful it was the worst experience of my
life oh I always make it seem like this
terrible thing that's scary yeah a lot
oh my god dude you're keeping tattooing
by scaring people off definitely get a
good tattoo artist spend more time
finding a good artist than your art
almost the quality of the art is
obviously important but I like getting
tattoos by people that I actually like
yeah yeah it's like are just like a jerk
the whole time you're like all right I'm
like yeah because it's kind of an
intimate experience with the artist too
yeah I get that you don't want to share
something with the someone you're lying
all right right right and then again you
know I came on a date afterwards you
know get to know him a little bit yeah
and if they hit the button in the middle
yeah then I go home you know I'm sad
I'm a pickup line go ahead I think
there's the classic did it hurt
there you go from heaven
um so painful right I'm working on my
dance person
out of here but the video isn't over yet
I think being able to have a similar
mindset on certain things like politics
maybe or like
future wise like are you gonna have kids
maybe not are you teetering if you're
gonna have kids or not do you find each
other attractive I think you're
attractive I think you're attractive oh
I think that I think that button for me
get to know you and see what happens
yeah okay me too this has been a long
day how are you feeling I'm feeling good
good where's this going consider going
on a second date with each other yeah
yeah for sure definitely do you want to
go out yeah
all right one last time I'm gonna go red
let's see what happens
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that couldn't go any other way that
had to be that way
really confront it you know you say yes
to something sometimes but then you're
you're in the moment of like oh do I
really have to do this boom no I don't
want to they gave her five bucks to do
that you know they're like lead them on
then push the button yeah I don't think
no back attackers see it coming from a
mile away I'm like a master oh oh you're
a master
like a Comey cute but I can I can see
these people they sit there I saw it I
actually saw it before you saw it
because I am the Masters master and all
these things the lowly Padawan teach me
master that's right I will
um all right next one I'll show you okay
wow I did one last opportunity I thought
you weren't gonna press I know why did
you press I feel like he knows what he
wants and I don't know what I want I'm
only 27 I'm still trying to figure that
out how's that bad how's that bad how is
that bad he can help you what the [ __ ]
is you want someone as messy as you are
what the [ __ ] is the way yeah that made
no sense
that hurt me actually
I don't know what I want he does and so
that's pressure
oh God she was my hero for a moment and
then she started talking to you we've
heard some bad ones but that one was
[ __ ] dumb I mean you're 27 how long
do you need to figure it out good God
yeah what the [ __ ] what have you been
doing this whole time I'm Alvin what's
your name Alex Alex yeah nice to meet
you you in school no I'm not do you
guess how old I am 24 27 27. yeah well
played man 23. okay what are you um
doing first
I forgot to say but I'm the master
master I knew that was gonna happen oh
you knew oh my god dude you are good
jeez yeah this is the best thanks wow
that was a short date why did you do
that just uh too old it's too old you
said she was 24.
but then he learned the truth you liar
learn the truth
lying smiling
25. if she was one or two years younger
you would have dated her huh yeah I
thought it age didn't matter that much
when you're older
do people still care like I never dated
anyone with all kinds of reasons it's
whatever it just makes no sense if he's
25 and she's like 35 maybe I'll be like
all right fine you don't want to date
someone that older but I don't know yeah
what what would be different if she just
lied to him and said yeah I'm 24. and
they went on a date and then later on
she's like I'm actually 27 he's like no
oh it can't be
yes yeah
I don't know I have actually been lying
this whole time I'm 200 years old
don't tell Marcia she won't be able to I
come I Come From Another World I am
actually a Wizard's Masters Master good
god this is my backstory and I've come
to destroy all Realtors radio hosts
and uh what was it else YouTubers
YouTubers thank you
and that is the backstory of why you got
your tattoo right there wow amazing
Debbie oh she's back again ladies
how old are you
oh is that well that's a bad question
you don't ask a lady that question yeah
she's also 200.
you know what I kind of believe it
honestly
no more Miss Nice Debbie
how are you oh I'm good nice to see you
again you guys like how old are you two
dated before we met each other before
yeah he hit me up on Instagram actually
oh wow
he did he's getting close why are you
single Debbie I just broke up recently
with my boyfriend Debbie's ex call the
cops on her
ah very interesting
that's a huge red flag um I think he has
a girl inside so he probably doesn't
want me to know Debbie's red flags are
herbs are you a perv Anton
no all right
that's what a perv would say that's
exactly what a part was
I like even put like a question mark on
it too like no
who am I
maybe Define it
did that perv yeah I have sisters and
know how to be classy and not an idiot
so if you have a sisters you can't be a
perv okay good to know bring me on a
first date we would go out to food and
then I like to go down to Red no and I
love music no it wasn't it was red for a
second like right when it spot back to
him it was red right and like right here
we would go out to whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] well spotted what the [ __ ]
that's my it's my superpowers you are
the Masters master master hey yes
is it all just editing because that
looks like an editing mistake look it's
missing some color here I don't think
the color actually changes did they did
they do this to me on purpose yeah well
I don't know each morning I get up I die
little can Billy stay and on my feet
take a look in the mirror and crying
till the end somebody
sorry
how could you reject that that was
beautiful
[Music]
are you sure are you sure like okay
what is that
you know if the button really was red
before that we noticed I wonder if like
this whole thing is just set up in this
stage like they're doing scripts that
this felt a bit scripted like yeah sing
really badly and then she'll press you
yeah you're right you're right okay that
is Master Masters Master uh kind of deal
what are you doing there Ken hello
Austin Austin what's your name Debbie
Debbie what do you do I'm a manager I
don't recognize uh he was in a previous
one and he's he's a jerk he likes
Carhartt apparently top to bottom
Carhart his own brand his own brand I
don't really care oh
harassing insurance companies and
dealing with uh
sometimes annoying patients why is he
talking to her like this you know
sometimes I harass patients oh
you're not helping you care you know I
like car horn how old do you think I am
oh I dare not say my lady but that
tattoo looks pretty aged maybe he's 32.
that's fine keep going
I can cook but not all the time what do
you cook simple things I'm not crazy
spaghetti oh oh I got her damn slid in
under the hand and she's like whatever
man
the technique that was well played he
did it while saying spaghetti he's
played before he's a pro he knows
whoever asks a whole bunch of questions
they're going to try to push the button
so he was ready for it he's the master
master
Next Level oh
who did it first I think I did right my
hand was definitely under if you guys
wanna well but I put it first but I
pressed his hand that brooched his hand
and therefore I don't think I go at them
get out of here I'm making it a tie
you're both out get the [ __ ] out of here
it just came out bro bro
I like how voice changed too he came out
like yeah I'm like taking care of people
and then he got voted I was like yo bro
yo what up with that
fake people can
can you love someone else
fake version of you
to be true to yourself
true true dating advice from master
master remember to subscribe so I will
not send you to Mars when I am the king
Overlord that goes for you Ken as well
oh oh yeah I am subscribed
again
you will live oh thank you
oh it's my birthday today is it yeah
when this video goes up oh say happy
birthday if today's my birthday say
happy birthday if today's your birthday
happy birthday
it feels so good yeah you got one hooray